what's your body cam two three hundred
i'm twenty seven miles shangri-la's
feeding
dms
dating apps i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm going to be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is grilling
my name aidan liam henry and i'm here to
look for a beautiful wife because i'll
just back her up and put her in the
place what you mean i've never been on a
first date like go sit down and boom
bang and talk about certain things i
just go
straight soon they see me it's a
matching you know i mean yeah you see
how i fight yeah you know i'm ready
come on baby girl
hi thank you so beautifully okay i'm
good thank you what's your name my
name's adrian henry how are you cheyenne
nice to meet you painting oh my god
i'll be fine i'll still take it away
you're shy a little bit no i don't need
to be shy i wasn't expecting him to be
shy you know today i'm going to be
rating you out of 10
on how good the date goes because i just
kind of find like men just waste my time
tell lies sell the dream i'm looking for
a real man i'm definitely a man yeah
i've been a man from a young age what
makes you a man from a young age
responsibility is
like no right from wrong you know what i
mean yeah
emotional intelligence so where are you
from i'm originally from rugby where i
moved to coventry because i was on a mad
case but i've been there ever since what
do you do i'm a professional boxer your
arms are nice and ripped
do you feel like a big man because you
fight for a living
i'm a big one just in general i guess
down my ground i don't think nothing
congratulations on your victory by the
way appreciate that so should we do a
cheers class
cheers to the next one 90th of december
hopefully i'll see you there yeah maybe
if the date goes well
you might see me there so i like that
confident engine you got there can you
bring it to me forget about the day
we'll see what happens what will happen
you tell me if i'm confident what do you
do for fun obviously i like riding
motorbikes fast cars so wild then yeah
it was in the bedroom of course am i
yeah you know some lighting
is it what
really three legs sorry for a little guy
got big dick energy yeah all right okay
we've got so much confidence
yeah looking quite shy
yeah i'm shy because you're a beautiful
attractive woman and you try to stick it
on me and i'm just like oh listen when
you sit in that hot seat you have to
take a grill in can't be going shy on me
so would you say you're romantic
why is this girl asking me so much my
questions she's sticking on me like yo
he's crazy have you got anyone on the go
at the moment train the lord sorry that
sheila lloyd means a holy pagal so
you're dating multiple women i'm not
dating a lot of women yeah having sex
with multiple women i'm not i'm not in a
relationship i just don't know how you
move though you listen you're single you
can do if i like you i'll lock up
everything would you do that if you like
a woman yeah of course i want to do that
have you ever cheated yeah once once
i've
when was the last time you had sex
three days ago two days ago do you have
sex a lot
you didn't you yeah got too much energy
man you know me i pressed gas man
stallion
is it like with the same person or do
you just have a different girl every for
a different day of the week
are you sure it depends on it depends on
how i feel how are you feeling now i'm
feeling very shy that's right i don't
bite though i'm not scared you're sure
you're just attracted to that and you're
sticking on but like you should be
talking like this
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna lie i thought he was gonna
come out and be a bit just like cocksure
but he seems really humble so do you
want a submissive woman that asks
nothing just sits there yeah you're sure
yeah how tall you're doing
do you find it hard to get women because
i know that swimming can be shallow no
because i've got confidence in it but
you know me i'm usually the person that
sticks that on them in it but you're
sticking out me now so i'm in my little
shower like
what am i gonna do
why don't you stick it on me then i'll
stick on me
[Laughter]
tough in the ring but not tough in front
of a woman
what's it like being a parent it's
something different in it i've always
wanted to have my own child you know
what i mean because i've never had no
parents
i've obviously
been through that mad life but yeah i'm
a good dad to my child in it that's good
she's beautiful man she's everything i
wanted in it
i don't know what it is about men that
are fathers but it makes them more
attractive when they're actually present
in their kids life
do you think fatherhood has changed you
in any way
yeah because obviously everything in
life is like what i get or get any like
if i get money it's not for me no more
because i know i've got shotgun and say
yo bam i'll go i've got to think about
my daughter i think about what she needs
think about her future you know what i'm
saying have you ever suffered with
mental health yeah stress depressed all
of that yeah like anxiety when you can't
leave the house
have you never had that
oh die i get anxiety bad yeah sometimes
i can't leave the house oh bless you
yeah it's really really bad
yeah we'll go through things you can't
leave the yard yeah there's that's just
wake you up man i'll make you feel
better how would you make me feel better
i need some jokes yeah i'll give you
some background banter good
night you're smiling at me not
diagnosing anything so i don't never got
mental health but i reckon so yeah but
just because
you're not diagnosed with anything like
have you ever felt like depression yeah
like suicide or anything like that
saying it maybe yeah suicide will it
yeah yeah i've said it a couple of times
i'll with myself
but really never i don't like i'd never
do that how do you deal with like
getting out of that kind of mental state
it's going to be wrong with people you
know it's important isn't it yeah have
you ever had like a complex
being like a shorter guy i'm a bit aggie
if you're not oh yeah so it's like
little man syndrome that's the thing
well that's from what i've been through
in it so it's not through your height
it's just genuine for your life exactly
yeah yeah yeah yeah obviously you're
always looking in there and i look at
them like what you're looking at then
look they're just look down that was it
if you see a normal sized person
see a small place yeah keep following
the person does it affect you mentally
anymore not anymore so it did at one
time yeah of course i just get annoyed i
sort of deal people in it but yeah i've
grown out there like i said i'm mature
now big 27 you know what i'm saying you
know who you are as a person so now it's
like no joe what he needs to give
himself more credit
he's what do you know he's the kids
yeah the kids
how old are you i know this i laugh
though how do you respond to children
doing it because of course i tell them i
said i'm not your dad but i'm the small
they're like no i'm saying yes
how do you like educate people because
the correct what's the correct term the
contribution that starts properly for it
okay educate me what do i know about it
i don't know i just feel like i'm i
don't sound like an [ __ ] but i'm
really ignorant to it because for me
like you're the first person that i've
met there's small what's the tallest
woman you've dated
normal size normal size but i mean like
have you ever dated a woman that's like
six foot i've never been with a small
person really since i've been famous
i've only been around little people but
before that before i come out again i
was famous i've never been around small
people i've been around growing people
in my life that's why i've got so much
confidence and you know i mean i'm just
normal that's why when everyone sees me
they come on it i don't see the command
as a small person i see him as a normal
person because how he brings itself you
know what i mean but when i see little
[ __ ] i'm looking up like they say
they baffles me up sometimes and it
makes me feel a bit weird yeah
cause i'm not used to it i've never seen
a minute when i see them they're good
man they're good man but they don't have
enough confidence that's how i do but
that's just their minute yeah everyone's
on their own journey yeah yeah yeah yeah
what's your body cam
yeah as you
active i'm 27 man 200 2 300. i'm 27
miles shangri-la's faded and you're
single no i am yeah
active common man i'm 27 when i was
shaggy when i was 13 but it's add the
numbers up in it did prison teach you
anything
like everyone's got their own age they
get to and they start saying yo enough's
enough in it i was in jail gotcha like
four years to when i was in 2017 and i
was in that of 2019 and obviously i come
out famous so
before if i didn't come out famous i'll
probably be back in jail right now you
know what i mean because i've got
nothing to come out for you know what i
mean so i've got i've come out got
famous and obviously i thought to myself
i've got opportunity to change my life
right now so why would i go do my silly
stuff i used to do before to put myself
back in there it don't make sense you
know what i mean so let me just give
this a shot and see how it goes in life
in it and right now this as long as i've
stayed at a journey my whole life that's
amazing no i mean i've done 10 years
behind the door not all together back in
and obviously don't get twisted i won't
tell anyone to go to prison or follow me
or follow anyone who's doing anything
stay on the right path go get a job and
let me do something successful in it i
like that cheers to that
i like your mentality
oh hey this guy's got substance you know
there's definitely more than he's
letting on what do you look for in a
woman
coca-cola bottle big back
and beautiful face nice personality
beautiful teeth
you've got a beautiful smile
it's very kind of you have really nice
eyes thank you very much have you looked
at my boobs whilst we've been here
we've got them out in it's all
do you want to cut it out i just want
everyone to see a minute because if it
wasn't it'd be zip-dopped
in it but i've seen them line it it's
just they're in it
what got you into fighting i've come
from a crazy background and i've always
been fighting from a young age so when i
was a bit a bit aggressive and because i
didn't have that father figure i was a
bit like
so everyone you say because i'm
aggressive like why did you just put my
aggressive into something useful so i
started doing boxing and obviously i've
done successful through the boxing keeps
me strong fit healthy and i'm ready for
anything what comes in my way you know
what i'm saying when i was young i've
always had someone to say oh you can't
do that you can't do this you can't do
this so i'm a proverb i'll prove my
point i can do it if i can do it anyone
could do it you know what i mean do
women like fetishize you
i've had some crazy women yeah you know
it is women are very curious about how
big my peen isn't it yeah i am curious
i like to lie
in it is it big though or just like
it looks big because you're shorter but
it's bigger than it it's big might hit
the spot in it okay
yeah yeah okay i actually really want to
know how big his dick is you don't get a
lot of small people so that is they're
curious about
what reckon how how do you reckon the
dick would be big small long bendy
sideways but little didn't they know
man's got the tripod like the camera you
know i'm saying
so
big and strong
what advice would you give your younger
self don't follow people don't get drawn
in and just keep it humble and just be
yourself and don't be shy to say no
yeah because that's what it is when i
was growing up obviously this little
this person like done their my [ __ ] to
me he had me like wrapped around my
finger in it it was crazy you know and
if he said jump i say hi yeah and i was
scared to say no okay i don't know it
was just weird i don't know how i got
around how i got to that situation but
it was mad like he smelled me going shop
i didn't want to go shopping she's going
to do this doing things i didn't want to
do is mad yeah but
i know all the kids out there in that
situation as well so don't feel afraid
to say no on it what would you say is
your biggest failure
taking people's things i should be taken
like breaking into someone's home taking
their stuff that's not me in it i'll
never do that right now you know what
i'm saying like i've done it because my
mum never had give me money i had to do
it to wear nice clothes to fit in with
my peoples and it was just mad but
that's my biggest regret like hurting
people making people come home and see
their things properties gone because i
would like that for myself you know
how people hurt people though yeah
yeah but it's nice to see though the way
you've just like turned your life around
but also like you come with a message
because it's really easy to sit and say
this but when like people can preach
anything all day long
they if you can't resonate with people
then people don't want to hear it but i
feel like your story like it's you
that's your experience and it's happened
yeah you can't move faster you let me
have your phone pass code it mean you
was together and i actually liked you
and it was like funny thing you can go
from my phone because there's not entire
it was just a little thing that i was
seeing a girl for a week she hadn't gone
on my phone going to my phone for what
yeah you know what i mean if i was with
you consistently for the whole month of
course like stealing my gut you must be
like oh didn't it
much like you as a person
booty play what are you all
yeah say yes then i don't know how
you're gonna take your ass
wait
i've never sucked a toe in my life
no i ain't got a problem with feet but
no feet are going in my mouth
massage your foot but i want that's all
right
i'm almost said yeah look at that
big toe
no chance no chance oh i've got a
pedicle just for you
would you be prepared to be a
stay-at-home father and let me be the
breadwinner so you can cook you stay at
home and cook clean raise the kids
that's the females job you're demanding
i'm like it's a female's job
i'm the man who brings the money to the
table so i've got go out there and graft
so when i come home my food is on the
blood clot table
so you want to be the breadwinner yeah
what if i want to be the one that goes
out and makes money no it's not that
hard for a girl it's the 21st century
women we are secure in the bag now you
can be the stay-at-home husband if i had
kids it wouldn't be like that because
you'll be looking after the kids okay so
you're alpha yeah of course i'm alpha
milan see it now lion yeah chestnut okay
quite weird didn't it of course a root
for you for me yeah
okay
well okay i don't know
[Music]
yes this is what i'm saying finally a
man that comes with the same energy one
rule for one rule for another it don't
make sense if you haven't beaten it on
my bedrooms yeah i don't give a [ __ ] no
because i think it's the imagery that's
right do you think yeah
so what what's that mean every black
bear [ __ ] yes
i like this do you think that like since
having a daughter though like your
mindset's changed with how you treat
women damn right you're mud my ex
relationship was a bit crazy right
they're arguing that that was what i
used to have when i was a young kid and
now i've got it now my daughter
i have to cut out i'm not on that
because imagine my daughter grows up and
she she's heard it from home so she goes
to when she gets to her age to a
teenager ages she finds her boyfriend
she likes the next minute mom i try to
slap her yeah you have to i'll catch it
you know what i'm saying it's not it's
nothing like that it's my baby girl you
can't be doing anything
have two girl freak out of xiaomi try to
anyway i think you might be a sub you
know what's a sub submissive
no you sure but you said you want me to
[ __ ] you yeah but you know what i'm on
about me and three gal and let's go ham
maybe more i don't care i'm not shy i'm
not kidding i'm not scared i'll just
manhandle everything listen i've had
threesomes here where men don't even get
involved because they're but they're
laughing that much yeah i'm just putting
in their work big man i go on gangbangs
with them they're like they just sit
there and laugh in the itch of the head
because my mom's getting comfortable
yo
when i press trigger blood i'm telling
you it's a biter yeah let's just be a
walk they're baffled how i just get down
in it
they're fascinated at the same time
because my thing's big and they're like
they feel maybe a bit shy at the same
time because my team's bigger than
theirs you know what i'm saying so when
i'm putting shifting they're like
well they're laughing because they're
boys in it you know i mean i've trusted
me on my kid's life i've been on the
mazda i've been on a mazda my bridge is
there laughing bending up and i was back
shot in the glass crazy
how big
can his dick really be
remember i've got mad energy in it
madden so imagine me naked and i posted
in front of me what you think i'll do to
it
it hurt me you understand okay all right
my head game is 10 10. really it's your
mouth game's strong strong your [ __ ]
your head gave 10 10 too
that's all right humble
could fit that much imagine in your
do you like a dominant woman yeah would
you dominate you
dominate me yeah
like in the bedroom are me in charge
of trousers are you wearing the blouse
shy could definitely not dominate me i'm
the dominator
i'd love to see him try dominate me
what would you do if i'd slept with two
of your friends in the past are you
staying with me
i'll press gas on you and cut really
yeah can't you just look off your
friends for me
yeah why because under one name is it
yeah if i was the one and i'd stuck with
two of your friends would you lock them
up for the love of your life no no
they're the ones that are ready to write
for me that they're the ones while they
do edit anything for me now listen no
one writes harder than a woman in love
trust me
what would you do if i wanted to start
an only fans
no no no i can't have any fans of course
not why because mine in it really says
not my body my choice why don't you make
money by selling your body why not so
it's a industry it's a profession that's
a drugstore what's mine is mine not for
everyone else to see you know what i'm
saying so whatever's in her underwear in
a back in their front in there up top
bottom i saw mine in it if she wants to
go do her tingle put herself out there
go be it that's her that's her in it on
her own
not me
so no to anybody
of course no to anyone i don't
understand why it's such an issue of
course it is you've got a boyfriend why
are you selling your blood body it's not
really it's just an industry isn't it
if you want to tell your body be single
in it why do you think it would affect
your ego
why is the next man looking at my
castings because i'm making money it
don't matter
the girls lost their
mind
what would you do if i wanted to involve
other people in our sex life
all right it's a bit weird do it yeah
i've had it really what if i was like
babe i really want to freeze some yeah
well if you would like if i liked you
know that wouldn't happen no no presents
no no would your friend maybe but no no
friends like the worst choice
but why would you my bridge
is my friend okay you'd have to be like
a no it's not gonna be a boy it could be
a gal but not a man i'd rather just
knock it nail on the head and say nah
you're just mine and
if you want to have a free song be
single in it like keep that without me
no cause i've never had that that that
thing so i can't say it's a bit weird if
i like child it won't happen no okay
what would you do if your friends are
liking all my selfies i'll stick it on
them oh yeah yeah of course i would
wonder why they're pretty much things
why not hype me
i'll hype you so you wouldn't like it
why is my bridge just looking at my
gastric support
support wire me
no darling no don't you want to see me
be great nice not to do that if i watch
your house 10 10. it doesn't matter it's
10 10. it's a standard listen when you
get with a girl
i know that's right
yeah of course but i'm just saying as my
virgin knows that's my thing that's it
don't look punner you can look part a
chapter or whatever and keep it neutral
but
call any five like liking pictures and
that's a bit taking a piss like i'm a
prick especially my friend but you're
liking my gal ting
so now me and you got a problem you know
what i mean yeah that part run man yeah
no violations yeah man you can't do them
what would you do if i didn't give head
well i'm not really ahead of gray in it
really what if the mouth game is like
strong it can be strong but i like to
throw all my babies in your belly
what would you do if i went to prison of
course i could visit yeah would you like
to sleep with other people though
depends how long you got
two years
what two years a very long time 24
months that way a thousand love it's a
long time for someone not to get after a
mate let me tell you you could be the
sexiest girl he could be the with a
baddest man
he told me not when a girl wants me the
girl's going to get
if i if i [ __ ] madly in love with you
and he's my kid's mom maybe but
do you think social media has ruined
love yeah and happy birthday what an
image
right yeah you see man with big changes
you think they're balling they're not
balling mate because it's their next
man's chains or jubal on instagram i did
when i come out of prison monster used
to take me to the jewelers and get this
chain next minute two weeks ago the
chain vanished so basically i was just
to make the instagram look good you get
me take it for the ground yeah thank you
for the ground but
i've i've had jewels i've had my own
[ __ ] but
jewels don't mean nothing to be normal
because you're not mean i've been there
i've done that you know i ain't got my
house here so i'm not happy in it yeah
i'm saying i ain't got my goals you have
achieved how do you think you've done on
the date sure [ __ ] yeah why because
you're still killing me that's why
i didn't know what to expect it was mad
it was just like oh
my god everything was coming out it was
my dipper's cute though thank you you
want to go for another date with no
cameras let me know in it
no it was a good date you know i'm
surprised i love a man with substance so
i underestimated him the date was a bit
mad because
obviously she stuck it on me in it
usually i'm the some person who sticks
out on them no we took the grilling okay
a little shy
second dates on the card i feel like i
needed him to be a little bit more alpha
i felt like i was dominating him a
little too much for my liking now the
grinding was lightweight man
i'm anything my dog chat about anything
i don't care
but she's stuck on me though don't get
twisted i was shy to [ __ ] he ticked a
lot of boxes like like an honest man
something that can open up the fact that
he's a good dad and that he's humble
however i just need a man just to
dominate me that little bit more you
know
don't underestimate him mate don't make
it don't make that beautiful face for
you mate do you know what i wouldn't say
no to a second date i feel
if if he can come through with the alpha
energy
maybe
i reckon i got a six or seven
yeah yeah
i don't care i'm gonna give him a 7.5
[Music]
you